je vous êtes le meilleur des menteurs
et toujours au nom de la vérité sans
doute avec le v majuscule
et aujourd'hui ce qu'on a sur les bancs
du gouvernement c'est le bal des faux
culs et députés ont voté un nouveau coup
de pouce pour les automobilistes face à
l'inflation la remise sur le carburant
va passer donc de créer un à 30 centimes
d'euro à la rentrée puis passer à 10 en
novembre et à 10 en décembre ce qui fait
que dans certaines stations service vous
auriez bien une remise de 50 centimes
d'euro sur les carburants il a besoin
d'elles s'est félicité que l'esprit de
responsabilité elle est emportée pour
protéger nos concitoyens y parle aussi
de compromis sans compromission
fondement a fait des concessions
importantes il a abandonné son usine à
gaz
hausse du nombre de kilomètres de
montendre nuxe terra au profit d'une
baisse générale vous ne comprenez rien à
la physique vous êtes des nullités
énergétique et au delà de ce bilan
pathétique vous êtes des irresponsables
l heure est venue trouver un accord et
et vice versa mais demain ce sera
possible dans l'arc républicain
évidemment monsieur jumelles dans de
nombreuses fois si vous êtes laissez-moi
terminer je vous prie soyez un petit peu
correct et poli ya le savoir-vivre
monsieur qui s'applique dans cette
assemblée mais également dans la vie en
général sur le front des incendies en
gironde les feux ne progresse plus celui
de la teste de buch est fixé depuis hier
mais celui de landiras pas encore en
raison de risques de reprise 200
pompiers sont encore sur place et depuis
hier il sécurisé la zone il s'agit comme
ici de repérer les braises encore
fumantes et de les noyer le plus
rapidement possible ils sont aidés par
les forestiers et vont poursuivre ce
travail de fourmi pendant plusieurs
jours encore table peine terminé son
propos je suspendrai après si si si si
en plus je vais pouvoir le faire dans le
calme puisque nos collègues de nubes
manifestement quittent l'hémicycle
incendies qui touchent également la
partie ouest des états unis en ce moment
la vague de chaleur et est aussi extrême
aux états unis des records de
température sont observés et regardez
cet incendie a baptisé havok fire il est
décrit comme explosif par les autorités
la fumée de l'incendié se voit depuis la
station spatiale internationale
hier le gouverneur de californie a
proclamé l'état d'urgence dans le comté
de mariposa
car selon les pompiers le feu va se
propager très vite ça fait toute une
série d' insulte systématiquement qui
viennent des pommes dans le fasse ce
n'est ni tolérées par le règlement il ya
des sanctions qui vont avec et là
maintenant ça suffit ce feu est l'une
des conséquences de températures très
élevées approchant les 40 degrés ce
week-end dans tout le pays joe biden a
décrété un état d'urgence y est à cette
vague de chaleur alors alors sinon
[Musique]
s'élance pour la france tenez acceptable
pour personne de comprendre que
l'ensemble du peuple est en train de
souffrir quand total énergie notamment
est en train de se gaver et ne me parlez
pas d'une pme lorsque l'on voit que
total a fait 16 milliards de bénéfices
quatre jours après l'agression de trois
policiers à lyon une personne a été
interpellée
il s'agit d'un ressortissant étranger
qui a été placé en rétention et sera
expulsé annonce le ministre de
l'intérieur la vraie justice c'est pas
d'aller taxer total reconnaissait que
c'est une facilité total a maintenu des
raffineries en france
cette raffinerie 5 appartiennent à total
5000 emplois pour une rentabilité qui
vous le savez est très faible je vous
informe sur le maire que ces pertes sont
uniquement due à des dépréciations
d'actifs
hors dépréciations d'actifs total même
en 2020 même quand le pétrole avait
réussi à être négative sur les cours
internationaux avaient réussi à faire 4
milliards d'euros de bénéfices sur ces
profitant temps ils pompent les français
depuis tant d'années